Ma va ma non vi impanicate la maturità é una passeggiata ve lo assicuro anzi se vi posso dare un consiglio
godetevi ogni singolo istante perché è un periodo meraviglioso ve lo ricorderete per tutta la vita
eh certo dicono tutti che é una passeggiata soltanto perché l'hanno già fatto
ri mortacci vostra calcolando i crediti accumulati se all'esame faccio scena muta mi promuovono lo stesso
ma tu conosci qualcuno che conosce i commissari esterni?
sessanta non fa paura cento non fa cultura
vabbè tanto dopo gli scritti ci sono ancora dei giorni per studiare
ragazzi facciamo un gruppo studio?
e se mi viene un attacco di panico e svengo davanti a tutti e crollo e rotolo per terra che figura mi faccio?
matura non ci fai paura yeah e se mi dimentico tutto
mo qualcuno mi deve spiegare come faccia a recuperare un anno intero in sette giorni
impossibile da domani studio una materia al giorno così non mi stresso e arrivo
preparatissima il giorno dell'esame
e se non so l'argomento della busta?
no scusa maria ma la busta non era una sola no perché io ne vedo tre sono un pò confusa
anche se mi metto a studiare il problema é che sto antipatica a tutti I prof mi bocciano di sicuro amo
manca una settimana alla maturità e io non ho ancora capito come funziona l'esame orale ma che me frega io non mi presento
a ma e basta un pò ti ho detto che mi metto a studiare dopo dopo sai che vuol dire dopo dopo
ma si tanto è una formalità
non è mica difficile come esame amo e se non riesco a trovare i collegamenti?
se non capita quella giusta scena muta e cambio busta ma secondo te no
si riesce a copiare?
pss sì dico proprio a te mi ha detto il prof di filosofia
che se non ti iscrivi al canale di mayna ti bocciano devi farlo assolutamente
io l'ho appena fatto e clicca anche sulla campanella vicino al tasto d'iscrizione mi raccomando
incrociamo le dita
si ma amo cioè se ce l'hanno fatta tutti ce la faremo anche noi un pò di fortuna no?
cioé me lo sento cioé
mi bocciano sicuro sicuro ho un certo languorino
mi vado a fare un bel bicchierone di magnesio non riuscirò mai a studiare tutto mai
no maria ti prego cioè chiudi la busta
Ma che stiamo scherzando
cioè io dovrei studiare tutta sta roba ma figurati vabbè dai questo non me lo potrà mai chiedere cioè non l'abbiamo neanche fatto
prof quando arriva a 60 anni fermi pure ma sai che me frega mi faccio bocciare e basta
oddio ho un vuoto non mi ricordo più nulla
scherzavo...
non mi ricordo niente di quello che ho studiato oggi niente
amo non posso studiare cioè prima devo guardare il nuovo video di maryna ovvio
che poi non s'è capito perché hanno cambiato la maturità ok amo quindi questa cosa non la studio perché non la chiede?
come studiala lo stesso non si sa mai??
Tra follia e innocenza mi basta la sufficienza e anche oggi non ho studiato nulla grazie a instagram
tanto ormai quello che so so
allora io ho deciso sentimi bene io fingo di avere la febbre
all'orale così faccio pietà alla commissione e mi promuovono non possono bocciarmi se sono malata
esame di fuoco comincia la danza dammi un 60 e vado in vacanza
oh vorrei proprio sapere chi é lo stronzo che ha inventato sta buffonata della maturità amo é ufficiale
siamo nella merda
qui si sboccia non si boccia ma come fate ad aver paura della prima prova è un tema d'italiano
facilissimo ave maria piena di grazia il signore é con te ti prego mi basta un 60
ambarabà ciccì coccò quale busta sceglierò basta voglio andare in vacanza
Ma questo argomento quando cavolo abbiamo fatto?
massi tanto i prof ci aiuteranno no? oh da domani inizio a studiare promesso eh
promesso
Ma perché ti preoccupi tanto se hai studiato durante tutto l'anno non hai nulla da temere sarà facilissimo
cioé amo appena finisco io li brucio tutti i libri cioé proprio faccio un mega falò
no vabbè io ti amo anche oggi si studia domani quindi cinemino? daje come sto?
amo ho l'ansia ho l'ansia e non mi ricordo niente e più studio e più non ricordo più non ricordo più ho l'ansia più ho paura di essere bocciata più
ho l'ansia e più ho l'ansia
Cioé ma io dico ma chi ce l'ha fatto fare di iscriverci al liceo cioè nel senso potevamo andare a zappare la terra no? ma stai
tranquilla non ti devi preoccupare perché agli iscritti si può copiare
io ti farò copiare